(laughing)
- What is this?
(robot cats meowing)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Built in sensors
allow these robot cats
to respond to petting and touch.
They are designed to provide the joy
and stress relief of real cats,
without any of the burden.
- My name is Clark.
I'm a cat lover,
and I will adopting a
robot cat for a week.
- I love cats.
Cats are life.
Cats are a lifestyle.
Cats are my spirit.
- Cats are real chill.
I'm chill.
Like, they do their own thing.
I'll do my own thing.
- You know, I already have
experience with real cats.
Why not give a robot a chance?
- (chanting) Robot cat.
Ro, no, what?
(laughing)
- Aww, oh my God, he's so soft.
(squealing)
- What?
(robot cat purring)
- Oh my cat is gonna hate this.
- Let's go.
You and I are gonna best friends forever.
No worries.
- All right, so here we are.
It's day one with my cat,
and I'm excited to see if this robot cat
can rival a real cat.
- All right.
Time to take my sweet daughter
Birdie back to Brooklyn.
Let's go introduce you to your cat sister.
- All right, so I'm about
to introduce my cats
to Lola right here.
Hey, Lola, what's up?
(mumbling) checking your cat, man.
(meowing)
- [Clark] Come here.
Do you not like your robot cat?
You never run away from me, robot kitty.
- [Brenda] Oh my God.
Who did that?
Look.
(meowing)
She's comfortable with you guys.
Belly up means that shit,
you know what that means?
Someone on the train was like
trying to get Stella's
attention, which was hilarious.
I'm like, she's not real.
- [Clark] Its back legs don't do anything.
It's got joints like it's supposed to,
so I wonder if it's broken.
- The one really cute feature
is that when the cat is left on,
and you don't pet her or anything,
she'll actually go to sleep,
and she starts snoring,
like it's suddenly so cute.
When I have work to do,
I'll just put her on mute,
or turn her off.
- [Clark] My cat is doing
really well at my desk.
my coworker's with her.
- This is disgusting.
(laughing)
And I love cats.
- It's not nearly as cool
as I thought it would be.
- So we're about to walk into --
(robot cat meowing)
Yes, that's right, Lola.
Our final interview.
You and I had amazing times together.
- It feels like actual company,
and it provides that peaceful moment
that cats are sometimes able to deliver.
So my week with Lola right here
has been very interesting.
It really reminds me of my real cats,
when they're behaving,
which means when they're
hungry and they need me.
- I'm lazy, so not having to feed the cat,
or honestly, maintain it at all was great.
- If what you're looking for in a cat
is emotional support,
this could do the trick.
This could do the job.
- But it did make me appreciate
the touch of a real kitters,
the response of a real kitters.
- The best part about owning a cat
is like winning it over.
I prefer to work for it.
I don't want a robot that
just likes me instantly.
- So there's a lot of things
a robot kitters are good for,
but when you got the
real thing in your life,
don't settle for a robot.
(robot cat meowing)
(upbeat music)